hey folks and welcome back to game
sports coverage of e3 2016 we are almost
done we've got a bunch of great games
coming up had delighted to be joined by
the pride of the great white north
copy bars own Nathan Vala how are you
doing sir that's a good intro like that
yeah do that great white north yeah it
makes Canada sound pretty awesome it's
such a really cool place it's pretty
cool yeah I like it some pretty cool
games coming out of it one of it you
debuted here three years ago yeah along
a wire friendly amount of time a
unexpected amount of time friendly
amount of time yeah we've been working
on the game for a long time we announced
it with Microsoft Andy through 2013
thought we were gonna finish it and made
me like 2015 and as we were making this
thing it just kinda took us in a
different direction and we decided to
give it a chance to kind of be what we
thought it wanted to be I mean it
whenever I talk about it like that I
sound like it's like it sounds kind of
strange to be like you have to let you
have to find the game yeah but really
what we found is it like giving our
studio a chance to explore an idea
usually results in better stuff than if
we try to dislike bad then oh that's a
good enough idea and nobody wants to
play video games that are good enough
ideas right really passionate about
trying to explore something to its
fullest and that you know sometimes it
takes a little bit of time but we're
super excited it's coming out this
summer we're very confident about being
able to nail that date we're working on
all of the fun things that come with
getting ready for launch already taking
a little break
in LA for a week yes I I am the whole
rest of the company is working their
butts off but I'm just kind of like I'm
chillin I'm just no I'm I'm taking a
little bit of vacay while I'm here
because I love LA a lot right and post
e3 you kind of need a little bit of a
yes in this stuff but he's like video
game overload Wow maybe few sir I just
played my first video game of e3
literally five minutes ago it was head
lander it was fun
head Landers so I guess what what was
the big shift like what was it before
and what is it now or is it so granular
that we're talking about now there there
are a lot of small like even just a
survival component of it
that the fact that you have to eat and
drink and stay warm those were things
that like we didn't really think much
about when we were originally defining
what the game was supposed to be and for
the first you know when we revealed it
those weren't really big gameplay
systems they weren't Horton crafting was
there but it wasn't the way that is
we've built it now where you have to
find fire and water and make soup or
stew like those things were things that
kind of you know came to light but then
there are bigger things like we always
wanted to do single screen dungeons we
always wanted to do kind of a zoomed out
camera but we didn't know how important
the concept of light and dark we're
gonna be in the game we didn't have the
kind of focus on we wanted to make a
game of exploration but we figured out
through development that part of the fun
and exploring is even just exploring a
single level right and darkness and then
having to figure out how to use your
either your torches that you craft or
your magical lantern which is like the
one kind of little piece of magic in the
game we had to figure out how to balance
that and the game became more about
these kind of conflicts the life and
death and how we deal with dying in the
game the conflict of you know light
versus dark of huge space versus a tiny
character and those things became
refined and became more interesting to
us and then we kind of just dabbled in
and we said why not give it a shot while
with the goal of creating something that
kind of feels a little bit different and
I don't think you can I think that if we
didn't explore it it would have felt a
touch different all right
so yeah the end result is a is a is a
very big game about a very tiny
character yeah and that's we're really
happy with the fact that we took that
time we're really happy that the fans
were not the angriest that they arrested
us a little bit to kind of keep going
and the result is that we get to when we
talk about it we're talking about a
project a game an experience that we we
feel pretty good about because we took
that time for sure sorry I mean you're
good oh it's good to ask how did you
decide like at what point the camera
would be stopped right leg yeah it it's
quite far away it is
it is so Chris our creative director one
of the cofounders of studio like
back in 2008 or something he was super
into roguelikes
and he was like kind of peeved that they
were kind of not the prettiest things
and that they were they're a very
different style of game
yeah and so he's really inspired by that
and at that same time you know we all
everybody on the internets has a 1080p
monitor or TV and we were kind of
sitting there saying like that's a lot
of pixels what can you do with that
that's not just the higher resolution
you know better textures move camera
closer and so at the very beginning of
the game pitch he pitched the idea of
pulling the camera back and and making a
game about teeny tiny little yeah I mean
and feeling weak and meager and one hit
away from dying but then giving the
player uh making them nimble and giving
them a move set that allowed them to do
to kind of battle that that small scale
yeah it's wonderful the sort of the fog
of war that surrender makes it seem like
there's so much possibility sort of
where you go people aren't familiar with
below so what what exactly what's the
other bit of it is it's it's like it's
it's a it's an adventure game inspired
by roguelikes about exploration about
survival and about discovery it's a game
where you play this tiny little
character we call them the wanderer just
because we don't know and the wanderer
is arrives at an island with a sword and
shield and backpack that you can put
stuff in and the very first time you
arrive you arrive with the lantern and
there is just one Lantern in the entire
game okay and so you we hand your
controller and we say there you go go we
don't there's no text there's no
tutorials there's no kind of like
narrative via somebody telling you what
the narrative and there is a narrative
but it's there for players to explore
are you expecting people sort of in the
guise of like something like super
brothers sword and Sworcery we're like
the internet sort of corralled together
and figured out a lot of the mysteries
around this game that is that is the
hope right it's not it's up to the
players to decide if they want to do
that and so because the way the game
works is that you're actually a new
character every time you die you're not
playing the same character over and over
again you're playing a sequence of new
characters arriving after the life of
the last one you can build on those the
successes of your past lives but because
of it you start at the beginning every
time but we're we're building these
systems that let players kind of
cheat let them kind of whether it's
through shortcuts or you can light a
fire at a fire pit and shine your magic
lantern on it and turn the fire pit into
a single-use checkpoint right so
essentially if you have enough power in
your Lantern and you want to you know
you you don't know where you are but you
think you're going somewhere interesting
you can create that checkpoint and if
you die then you can have a you can
basically quick travel to the point
where your corpses pick up the stuff
that you had fly and find the lantern
that you might have dropped yeah and
carry on but you can only do it once you
need to then set another checkpoint so
the idea of like using again the whole
idea is to make death something
interesting in the game it happens
frequently and frequently because if you
get hit you bleed if you don't stop
yourself
all right you die Wow so you're going to
die but death is a piece of gameplay
because you're building on the success
of the last lives because you can find
those shortcuts unlock those shortcuts
and then never have to do with that
super hard part ever again because you
already dealt with it in a past life it
is there a case in which somebody can
get quite far deep somewhere die drop
the lantern and then it's incredibly
difficult for them to get it again
absolutely but there are other kind of
I'm not gonna say safeguards but there
are ways to supersede that extreme
challenge yeah
but yeah you don't need the lantern to
at all times but the lantern is critical
to exploration in the game and it will
it not having it will sometimes stop you
from being able to do certain things so
there is a balance what another thing
you can do is at fire pits you can
either cook to make your soups and
potions well are equivalent of potions
and you can go into this place that we
call the pocket which is kind of like a
like an old final fantasy style safe
zone almost where I pull out of the game
you pull out of time inside of the game
and you can leave your weapons you can
leave the lantern you can stock items
and they're there for any other life so
you can kind of basically prepare for
more challenging journeys when you're in
the easier part of the game and stuff
left there can be picked up by any
future character so you can do things
like set checkpoints explore or set
checkpoints go into the pocket leave
things and then explore and if you die
you know where your Lantern is you know
you
some supplies to go further and you know
you can get right back to where you were
if you're smart and if you're exploring
with with purpose right it's quite
morose it's like oh okay I'm probably
not gonna get much longer in this life
like past this one day Bank all my stuff
here yeah what you're seeing right now
is is the pocket area and it's you know
there's a fire there's a place to hang
your lantern there's a little
clothesline there's even a place to
store your gem it's because you collect
gems off of enemies that you kill and
they're the fuel for your Lantern they
also have other purposes in the game as
well so you can just kind of sit there
in in in the pocket and lounge you can
actually just sit by the fire and hang
out if you want only gathered from
enemies or what can you like you can you
can scavenge for there's kind of a flora
and fauna within the game the closer to
the surface you are the more natural it
is the more plants and animals there
will be and then the deeper and darker
it gets the more weird those items
become and you can you know you can find
everything from potatoes to cabbage to
you kill bats and harvest meat from them
you can you can you can kinda you can do
it you can harvest stuff from humanoid
enemies like cloth and leather and those
are all pieces of the crafting and I
mean there's recipes like the I'm
guessing there's no like cookbook in
this that's all like could be people
gonna discover that themselves yeah
we're like any man I don't know if you
guys cook I personally like to cook
myself and and when I make soup you put
like some stuff in a pot yeah and you
dump a bunch of things in it and you
boil it for a while and kind of no
matter what you put in there it kind of
makes a soup right right that will
always always be able to make something
at least that will deal with hunger and
thirst or you might not taste too good
it's definitely not gonna give you buffs
right actually not gonna heal you're
bleeding all the way those are all saved
for the bigger kind of special recipes
and those are for players to find other
recipes something like when you discover
a recipe per se doesn't save to
something that you can refer back to
later we're still kind of sorting out
that piece of the puzzle to be totally
honest where we want it to be it's not
something that you can just kind of like
you know we want the list of crafted in
the ideal scenario the list would be
shared amongst players right rather than
being
defined by us yeah but it is kind of
like that might actually be super
friggin frustrating and we might just
kind of let you do that but I'm a huge
fan of like playing some games the piece
I did that I know if you guys played
device 6 on iOS but yes so I have like
drawings and same thing with the windows
like that so we're mean you know we
don't want to obligate anybody to do
that but that's again there's we have
these kind of like we have these ideas
in the game and then we have the ideal
scenario of people playing it whether or
not they do that's totally up to them
they can play this game however the heck
they want but it'd be really rad to see
people's if if you take notes while
playing our game please send them I've
got a bunch of questions coming in I
want to get to scrub econ asking a co-op
do you guys have any multiplayer plans
here it's a single-player game that's
something we would we would really like
to think about but for now we're really
focused on what the single-player
experience is it's a game that like
again as we kind of worked on it we
realized the feeling of scale really
merges well with the feeling of
loneliness and you know the weight of
the world being on your shoulders and so
yeah it's it's a single-player
experience but it's something that like
obviously you know word it sits in the
head it's a never aim you know what I
push this one out another year yeah yeah
if if scrubby cat would like to fund the
delay I guess I'm sort of interested in
how I mean indie Studios usually pretty
scrappy right like trying to like hustle
to get the next game at what is it about
a copy bottle edge you guys to like be
able to like take like a intake of
breath and be like you know what
actually we'll just leave this one be
another 12 months like put that time in
well I mean part of it is we've had some
games that have done well enough that
give us the financial freedom to do that
but the other part of it is like we just
we understand that our best chance of
making games that matter to people is by
making them as good as possible right
and that that that is a firm like that
is just the way that it works to me yeah
I think that's the way that the player
that's what players expect from smaller
more kind of air quotes creative game
expect something to be fully realized
they don't want half-baked cool little
games they want fully baked cool middle
games the bigger games they could they
play in a space where they have to be
complete and tight yeah we have the
ability to be a little bit looser I'm
getting out my earpiece here at the
moment and I'm actually privy to all the
wonderful music that's playing at Jim
Guthrie again yes Jim Guthrie back and
he has like 200 minutes of music for
this game we have right idea what we're
gonna do with all of it fans of Jim
Guthrie know him from sword & Sworcery
from indie game the movie he also has
done a bunch of other work and is in you
know back in Toronto it was kind of an
idiot end but the soundtrack for this
game is very different Jim is a genius
and a big part of the game is the
ambience is the tone and his music
instead of coming in and just being like
amazing jim song by amazing jim song
it's kind of like mixing his beautiful
songs with a longer soundtrack i think
it's really really rad and i can't wait
for people to hear the whole thing nice
they can thank you so much for coming on
thanks for havin have to ask you were
you responsible for releasing that
capybara in toronto i found one of them
they found one on one oh really they
found the male the the the lady capybara
is still at large
yeah I kind of wish that I was in
hindsight because that would have been
the best marketing of all yeah you got a
freebie yeah we did thank you very much
Toronto Zoo bring Toronto Hyde Park Zoo
okay the full zoo is this is just a
little tiny one all right they've zoo
wars in Toronto absolutely Wow you don't
you don't get in the middle of that it's
like Mafia 3 except you thank you thank
you so much for coming in when is below
available where can people find out more
about what lies below com it's coming
out this summer we should have a firm
release date very soon because the
summer is actually just starting and yes
it's only 3 months long so that window
is is is locked and loaded it's coming
to PC for Steam and Xbox one as well and
we're super excited to finally get it
into players hands don't just stop
talking to you about it right yeah let's
talk about next year you know what we
got some stuff cooking and I'm super
excited good stuff thanks so much for
coming in thank you folks for watching
we've got a bunch more great games
coming up here
wrap up our final day on the electronic
triple show floor next one up again I'm
very much looking forward to talking to
the developers about its ukulele be back
in two minutes